all right um this is something a little
different you know i get
so many emails probably like eight to
ten emails a week from people who either
want to start a podcast youtube channel
or independent media show
or who have started it but it's not
going as well as they want and they want
advice from me
and it's beyond the scope of the 24
hours that i have in the day
to to be doing too much of this kind of
individual guidance but there
are a bunch of different people over the
years that have come to me for
advice people i know personally uh or
people that are introduced
to me and um they often have very
similar questions and the point of
failure for almost everybody is exactly
the same
and i sort of tweeted about this
yesterday and a bunch of people wrote
back and said you should really kind of
talk about this
um being you know as not we're i believe
in the top
point one percent of youtube at this
point and uh having done it and having
gotten to the point of hiring staff and
having a successful business model
what is it that causes people to fail
and unfortunately
fortunately or unfortunately the the
good i have good news and bad news and
it's all the same
the biggest single point of failure is
essentially not showing up
um when i will talk to people who have
started shows or want to
they often will jump to things like how
do i negotiate a brand
deal what should my youtube thumbnails
look like
what kind of equipment do i need for my
podcast when can i
monetize and so often the cart is being
put before the horse
and what i tell everybody is all of that
stuff
will come naturally you'll figure that
stuff out when the time comes
once you are actually steadily and
consistently and reliably producing the
content this
this isn't like the bogus 98 is showing
up
this is just the reality that people
will often focus on things that aren't
the most important now obviously
if your content is terrible some people
just like
they're you know the content's not good
assuming
that your content isn't terrible where
almost
everybody fails is they get discouraged
too early there are overnight successes
in independent media of course there are
um but the vast majority are not
and people will come to me and i'll say
you need to pick a content schedule and
stick to it are you doing a weekly show
are you doing daily youtube clips are
you doing a twice a week show
or what is the format and the timeline
that you are
committing to and sometimes people will
hear that
um and and they will keep it going you
know i remember in fact
years and years ago meeting up with kyle
kalinski when both of our channels were
much smaller
and the thing we talked about as we both
were looking to grow
at the time that he actually did and he
now has a channel that is doing really
well
is you've got to commit to the schedule
of content that's actually the key thing
we didn't talk about
monetization brand deals thumbnails we
we
talked maybe about a you know what
microphone do you use but it was all
about the content and so i'll have
conversations with people
and ninety percent of the conversation
is about things that don't really make a
difference
and then they'll say yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna do the content six months go by
i'll come across their youtube channel
and it'll say oh their their latest
video is six weeks old
you've done no content for six weeks and
sometimes we'll have another interaction
and they'll say
yeah you know it just wasn't as
lucrative as i wanted it to be it's like
well but you're not publishing the
content
you have to do that first the other big
mistake
is sometimes just scaling up expenses
before it's time
i know of shows that are one-tenth the
size of our show
where the host will tell me they already
have
an executive assistant who responds to
their email and schedules their
interviews
what what that doesn't make any sense
and i from a business standpoint i've
talked before
about the push cart method one of my mba
professors would talk about the push
cart method
don't necessarily go to a restaurant
with an expensive lease and tons of
employees
try the food with a push cart a food
cart and if it does well then you roll
that into maybe getting the restaurant
and this is like
the the most important thing that i that
i tell people and most of them fail to
do it and there are tons of shows that
could do fine the content's good
um but people just don't show up and so
you know unfortunately i i at this point
i'm unable to provide individualized
advice
to all the people who email me but if
you're not doing the content
don't be surprised that none of the
other stuff is going as well as you want
it to go
hopefully that's useful to some people
and i think that that's what we
committed to early with the show which
was when we were twice a week
we were twice a week and we were doing
the content and we were putting up the
clips in the podcast episodes
when we went to when when that was
supported
financially we then went to four times a
week
and we did it and then when that was
supported financially we went to the
five
and people can count on the content it's
the most important thing
it's the biggest point of failure and
the real reason why tons of people i
mean
it's dozens and dozens of people over
time who have emailed me saying
i want to do what you're doing but it's
just not happening you didn't do the
main thing i said which is commit to the
content schedule